and bra tell you the truth you can see
them set but this look big you got this
Mac absolutely I can really see how I
said to Chinese nice to meet you nice to
meet you Mike what's going on man Suchi
got absolutely loves sunglasses you know
these glasses really have to see the
future well let me show you I got to see
Grammys come on brownie babe come in for
a minute
that's a nice jacket you got amazing
second a caramel boy deploy here because
we talk about you know more things
outside of music you know he's it's well
known huge EDM producer DJ I'm this
hip-hop icon and we happen to actually
be friends we talk about you know women
and dances and songs sports in glasses
so you know we would like to see what
you have because he has on some pretty
nice looking for I got some demons not
pop in my ears is though this is like a
modern like almost like a luxury low
you'll see there's gold laid on the
inside there's gold hits on the back and
then this is a marble and then within
the white marble there is a crocodile
laser etched imprint in there your face
of shape this is kind of egg shape this
doesn't really look good or if you're
just all rose gold everything like funky
that embellishment on the front is an
Allen bull which is like a reference to
skateboarding those are the bolts you
have on this oh yeah yeah yeah we scared
ups we do that we do some kick kick
pushes down the hill and nollie kickflip
wait how much would these were me
because I really like these doesn't hunt
it swinging like these snakes can 110 oh
so they're very reasonable very
reasonable not a [ __ ] that what's in
here yeah let me know wait in this case
I got these special cases when it come
down it's all about presentation yeah
yeah so you got a briefcase with another
safe in it this is a carbon fiber
compartment
it's protected by electronic password so
titanium Halliburton briefcase carbon
fiber compartment protected by
predictable Viper
yeah and inside this is a crystal lens
but on the side you'll see 400 handset
white VVS diamonds on that side and
another 400 white BBS handset diamonds
for a total of 16 carats good news you
know I forgot to tell you you're
supposed to be wearing these white
gloves but yeah bunch of jewelry so [ __ ]
it I did wash my hand before you know if
you want to do it official there's one
but it's up to you know just I'm not
gonna ask you or the white glove after
the fact the dock you might want yeah
that I can afford them so you so what
happens if we break these what happens
if we put diamond pops out you know I'm
always on stage yeah if anything
anything happens to those glasses
they're covered for life they'll be
fixed with a diamond pop stop we will
replace the diamond but it's just not
gonna happen the level of quality and
craftsmanship that goes into these
glasses is literally top-shelf we're
done by the best jewelry makers know
this isn't boring like the beach this is
for stunting really hard can you try
them on oh yeah please try them on
whoa whoa so what a pair of you know 800
individually diamond set glasses
this is $48,000 you know me to change
being a sunglass kind of store that I am
with over a quarter mil in inventory and
just of the finest friends ever it was
very interesting me my man Mike who owns
and runs nine five sunglass no diamonds
on shakes I could see me doing that
pretty fancy but I can't drop that fifty
so I'm gonna say counter to [ __ ] but not
so to [ __ ] pista nine five thank you for
the collection see you guys soon true